so Neil did you know that Marina made a
video animation of your asteroid no I
didn't know that yeah all right Marina
show me it shows orbit for the next year
you know you you need to know to keep
track of your asteroid for the following
year to keep track of my real estate yes
okay and I I use their super secret
software to visualize it oh my gosh so
this is my escape plan if I want to
escape Earth you just have to figure out
how to get there
this oh my gosh so that's one out of
like a gazillion asteroids there and boy
the solar system looks like a busy place
it is a very busy place so there are
millions of objects in the main Bell
possibly billions but you have a
pretty hefty asteroid and it's a binary
I know so that makes it extra special
how much could he sell it for tonight